trois couleurs impossible de les rater
marie-madeleine gréard emelia ouvrier de
france en broderie couleurs en fait j'ai
toujours bretez depuis mon plus jeune
âge parce que autrefois n'y avait pas
d'autres choses avec maman j'ai appris à
faire le point de tige et j'ai toujours
un drone et mai
je me suis mise à broder vraiment il ya
une quinzaine d'années en partant de mes
aquarelles si elle participe à la
journée européenne des métiers d'art
c'est pour montrer que la broderie est
aussi un moyen de s'évader
trois autres artisans étaient invités
par le parc naturel de la haute vallée
de chevreuse les journées européennes
des métiers d'art c'est l'intérêt c'est
que les artisans d'art ouvrent leurs
portes pour montrer leur savoir faire et
transmettre leur savoir faire au château
de la madeleine on propose à ses
artisans d'art en fait de venir s'ils
n'ont pas la possibilité d'exposer chez
eux souvent ou une activité qui ne
permet pas d'ouvrir leurs portes parce
que là lors d'ateliers sont trop petits
cinquante quatre artisans sur le parc
naturel ont ouvert leurs portes
plus de six mille événements ont eu lieu
dans toute la france